this is a tough business oh no I know
you're a tough guy Jeff and it's and we
need to have a leader that is put real
tough it's the fifth yes fifth GOP
debate of the year and we watched it so
you wouldn't have to or so that you
could relive the magic with us in either
case these were the three best and worst
moments of the fifth GOP debate the
third best moment we have to have a more
realistic foreign policy and not a
utopian one where we say oh we're going
to spread freedom and democracy and
everybody in the Middle East is going to
love us the third best moment of the
debate was delivered by the candidate
formerly known as libertarian ish r and
fall while the rest fought over which
parts of the map should be carpet-bomb
Paul summoned the ghost of his father's
campaign and pushed back on the gops
lust for regime change in Iraq Libya and
now Syria it has not worked out of
regime change you get chaos from the
chaos you've had you've seen repeatedly
the rise of radical Islam so we get this
profession of oh my goodness they want
to do something about terrorism and yet
there's a problem because they allow
terrorism to arise out of that chaos and
let your shoulder the second best moment
I believe it admit that America first
foreign policy instead of being a
Woodrow Wilson democracy promoter we
ought to hunt down our enemies and kill
Isis wasn't just Rand Paul questioning
Republican foreign policy orthodoxy at
number two on our list both Ted Cruz and
Donald Trump exposed the growing rift in
the GOP over military intervention in
the Middle East we have done a
tremendous to service not only to the
Middle East we've done a tremendous to
service to humanity the people that have
been killed the people that have been
wiped away and for what it's not like we
had victory it's a mess and the best
moment of the 5th GOP debate how do we
keep America safe from terrorism Trump
says we ought to close that internet
thing
the question really is what does he mean
by that for our top honor we turn back
to none other than the Kentucky senator
reanimating his inner libertarian with a
spirited defense of American ideals that
are under assault by other candidates I
think if we ban certain religions if we
censor the Internet I think that at that
point the terrorists will have one okay
okay that was pretty great but let's not
forget that Rand Paul is absolutely
terrible on the issue of immigration
which leads us to our third worst moment
of the night the third worst moment he
thinks he wants to be this oh I'm great
and strong on national defense but he's
the weakest of all the candidates on
immigration he is the one for an open
border that is leaving us defenseless
other Republicans were also quick to
demonize immigrants in the wake of the
San Bernardino attacks particularly
refugees we will not be admitting
jihadists as refugees refugees who will
be infiltrated with terrorists I
guarantee you for him not to be what to
be terrorists malpractice I'm not going
to let Syrian refugees any Syrian
refugees in this country and it was
widows and orphans by the way but the
fact is it wasn't a refugee that carried
out the attack it was an American born
citizen and his fiancee who post about
her desire to wage jihad on her Facebook
page the second worst moment you talk
freedom to speech you to a freedom of
anything you want I don't want them
using our internet to take our young
impressionable youth Republicans aren't
just determined to stop the flow of
people but of ideas by trying to clamp
down on the internet and encryption
technology there is a big problem it's
called encryption and the people in San
Bernardino were communicating with
people who the FBI had been watching
never mind that the FBI hasn't confirmed
that the attackers used any encryption
simply that it existed on their phones
just as it does on almost every
smartphone everywhere and the worst
moment of the fifth GOP debate keep our
nation safe keep America safe keep
America safe keep our kids safe the
atmosphere of apocalyptic doom
cultivated by both candidates and CNN
made this entire debate a generally
miserable event whose worst moment can't
be whittled down to a single sound bite
suffice it to say
the candidates seem to be jockeying for
position as the bomber in chief most
likely to start World War three you know
we've got a phobia about boots on the
ground if our military experts say we
need boots on the ground we should put
boots on the ground we need to focus our
attention on Iran because if you miss
Iran you're not going to get Isis
frankly it's time that we punched the
Russians in the nose oh wow
agree/disagree or have other moments you
think we're particularly good or awful
let us know in the comments
[Music]